hello guys so the trailer for secret
invasion was shown behind scenes and i'm
going to give you the footage breakdown
the trailer begins with nick fury
returning to earth via a spaceship and
appearing to murray hill at a bar who
states that she's been unsuccessfully
trying to reach him for years vara asked
nick why after all this time has decided
to come back and nick says that that was
an issue that needed his attention now
kobe smoulders one of the actors said
this is a darker show and we're going to
get deeper into the characters and it's
an exciting thriller and she wasn't
exaggerating when she says this series
is a darker thriller as we get quick
glimpses of tylos amelia clark shooting
a gun kingsley benady with shapeshifting
heavies and olivia coleman talking to
nick fury saying you're in no shape for
this fury we also get a glimpse of don
cheadle as war machine and the people
who have seen this trailer saying it
looks like one of the darker disney plus
series almost given off captain america
the winter soldier vibes now i've got to
say i really like the darkest stuff in
mcu so i'm really excited to see this
show because i'm going to be honest i
wasn't the biggest fan of love and
thunder i'm not sure if that was to do
with the tone or not but i am excited to
get a break for more of the
light-hearted and comedy-centric marvel
films and tv shows and get more of a
darker and grounded series so i feel
like secret raisin would definitely be
for me but let me know your thoughts in
the comment section below are you
excited for secret invasion and what do
you think of this series so far based of
what we have just heard and if you
haven't already please like and
subscribe thanks for watching guys